معنى من ستوكهولم الوزير الدفاع لوسمبورس
مرحبا بك سيد فرونس
ويعني العنوان العام هو دعم اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه لكن اذا اردنا ان ندخل شيئا ما
بالتفاصيل هل هناك خطه جاهزه
ولائحه محدده بما ستدعم به اوكرانيا
الاجتماع في الوقت الحاضر يسير بطريقه
حسنه لان المقترحات التي وضعت من السيد
بوريل للانضمام الى القوات الاوروبيه لكي
نستطيع ان نتوصل الى طريقه مشتركه حيث
تكون فعاله في تقييم الاسلحه والذخائر الى
اوكرانيا وهذا تم قبوله بشكل جيد وتقريبا
كل الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
موافقه عليه اذا انا متفائل جدا بانه من
الان الى العشرين من مارس حيث سنلتقي
كوزراء الدفاع ووزراء خارجيه في بروكسل ان
نقوم بوضع اللمسات الاخيره لكي تكون
الصوره واضحه لكي نساعد اوكرانيا في وضعها
الحالي قلت اجماع نوعا ما هل هناك اعتراض
من بعض الدول
لا ليس هناك اعتراضات على الاطلاق الكثير
من الدول حسب اعتقادي سوف تقدم ضمانات
بنها سوف تعمل بكفاءه
والمساله المتعلقه الان بقضيه تقديم
السلاح هو التنظيم والترتيب وهذا الامر
يدرس الان على الطاوله بطريقه ايجابيه
ومزاج ايجابي ونحن نناقش هذه القضايا وانا
متفائل جدا بانه سوف يكون هناك اجماع كامل
في العشرين من مارس
هل هناك جديد في الاسلحه التي ستقدم هل
هناك نوعيه اسلحه لم تقدم سابقا لاوكرانيا
وستقدم نتيجه هذا الاجتماع
نعم
الاسلحه الاهم اليوم لاوكرانيا يتمثل في
ملم اي اسلحه على سبيل المثال البلدي
في الاشهر الاخيره على تقديمي
عشر عربات مليئه بالاسلحه عيار 155
ملم لان هذا ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا في الوقت
الحاضر لان عليهم ان يدافعوا عن انفسهم في
الجبهات الاماميه ومن ناحيه اخرى من المهم
ان يتمكنوا من الدفاع عن انفسهم في الشهر
ونصف شهر القادمه لكي يبداوا بعمليه
هجوميه في ابريل او مايو لاننا نعلم ان
الكثير من الجنود الاوكرانيين يتدربون على
التراب الاوروبي الان وسوف يعودون الى
بلدهم بتدريب افضل وبصلاح احدث اذا فنحن
الان في لحظه صعبه الان ولحظه حاسمه لذا
فمن المهم للمقاومه ان تستمر كما هي اليوم
في اوكرانيا
ومن اجل هذا فهذه الاسلحه والذيره هي
الامر الاكثر اهميه الان هل تصلكم اخبار
باخموت والحديث عن
سيطره
فادينر على القسم الشرقي منها بالكامل هل
تصلكم هذه المعلومات وبالتالي الا يلعب
الوقت لصالح روسيا
كلا اعتقد
انكووف قدم مراجعه كامله للوضع على
الجبهات
وبالنسبه للمعركه في بخمه هذا الامر حاسم
ولكن الاوكرانيين ببسالتهم وشجاعتهم هم
يبقون الوضع تحت السيطره الان وفي الوقت
الحاضر الوضع حاسم ومهم ولكن هم يسيطرون
على الوضع بصعوبه والرسل بالتالي ليس
لديهم فرصه للتقدم اذا فكما اشرت فان
تقديم هذه الذخائر والاسلحه الان للواجهات
للجبهات الاماميه امر مهم جدا وحاسم ما هي
الاسلحه
التي او الذخائر التي عليها خط احمر بمعنى
انه لن يسمح بتقديمها
لاوكرانيا او يخشى الاوروبيون من تقديمها
لاوكرانيا
الاحمر واضح نحن سنقدم اسلحه تقليديه وهذا
امر واضح جدا
واعتقد
ان هذا الامر لازم جدا الان للدفاع عن
البلد
لصد الروس والفوز وكسب هذه الحرب اذا فهم
بحاجه للدبابات وربما انظمه الدفاع الجويه
والذخائر
لكي يستطيع
ان يبقوا الجبهه ثابته وصامده وفي ابريل
ومايو سيكون هناك بدء بعمليه هجوميه ليصد
دروس من منطقه دومباس ولكن الخط الاحمر هو
يشمل التدريب فقط لهؤلاء الجنود من قبل
اوروبا وارسال اسلحه تقليديه لان هذه
الحرب تقليديه
من وزير الدفاع لوكسمبورج فرنسوا شكرا
جزيلا لك